[Music]
in her young news forever young forever
young
I don't wanna be young what I do you
want to live forever
yeah but then yeah but there was a guy
on the jacket talking back there forever
[Laughter]
my name Hector Munna Hector a 69 year
old man who identifies as a 20 years
younger has launched a legal battle to
change his age 49 he identifies as 49
Troy hilarious I like this guy he
definitely like the mental like a
thought process to see if I like oh you
know it's kind of interesting there's
legal ramifications for that -
retirement he's another's all of that
[ __ ] insurance like loses Social
Security yeah what's the point of him
identifying as a 49 year old okay we're
gonna die so this man there's a Dutch
man his name is Emile Emile
[Laughter]
he runs a like reddit to ease their
character named Emile his brother his
brother's name was Nick anyway so this
dude he is a self-help group guru in an
entrepreneur everybody's an entrepreneur
I'm an entrepreneur apparently you are
barely
[Laughter]
so he's saying that he got a medical
check and that the doctors say that his
biological age is like about 45 years
old I think I was like a really healthy
body also he's very healthy
and still keeps saying that he saves
body before noon I know exactly how I
feel good yeah so he's saying that being
69 years old are being viewed as 69
years old it's very limiting for him
because people won't hire him as a
consultant when he's on tinder women
don't really hit him up cuz he's so old
then like you [ __ ] sack of [ __ ] why
is that so hard
pretty easy you just put your [ __ ]
age of them and if they see you you look
healthy and fit and you [ __ ] go get a
job any pure nature entrepreneur and
[ __ ] himself out guru why you need a job
I hate people that fake entrepreneurship
whatever I don't know so yeah I feel
really good then your track records yeah
more than age does I would want a
ninety-year-old who's a [ __ ]
consulted yeah more experience what the
[ __ ] is he talking about I think his
argument here is that if transgender
people can are allowed to change their
sex on their birth certificate then why
can't he change the date of birth I
don't even think I don't know this is
[ __ ] ridiculous
so he's saying like the positives for
the government is the whole like his
pension thing like they he wouldn't be
claiming it until he reaches that age
again if he makes it maybe he's doing it
to prove a point
he looks [ __ ] 69 what the [ __ ] that
bull looks like he's basically a two
steps away from being blind my look at
that [ __ ] no he still looks 69 yeah look
at that lucious has hair yes great hair
though
yeah [ __ ] yeah he's saying like he's at
least 20 years younger and like so he's
arguing like why can't I changed my date
of birth from 1949 to 1962 the [ __ ]
ball sack dude a ball sack on demand is
like the rings on a tree you can't lie
so bleak all of a sudden it gets that
bad well they'd start to droop when
they're older just like titties do so
there's less wrinkles then exactly so
that the length of the droop is like the
rings on a tree yeah so you can't lie
about that ball sack droop spots on it -
yeah I hope he's not serious you're the
only person that with a sauna pull you
look weird did it supposed to help you I
was rubbing my eyes it happens sometimes
do people pay good money for that [ __ ]
bro I don't want it I don't want it well
the judge just voted to deliver a
written ruling within four weeks well I
have to take this kind of [ __ ] serious I
would have been like are you [ __ ]
stupid that's what my response would be
I feel like that every guy has to change
their legal age down ten years because
they're mentally ten years younger
oh yeah you know that like if you let
that be legal done like [ __ ] have you
had a conversation with these three men
right here though maybe thirty
down excuse me I have a wisdom of a 60
year old of a 60 year old but I have
life preferences of a 12 year old BAM
boom beezy what does that mean yeah play
a flute after you say that [ __ ] - point
please point proven
[Laughter]
[ __ ] genius proof point it got mixed
up we all knew what you meant
until you fixed it in them you're like
oh [ __ ] that's gonna be another t-shirt
please how about be selling them soon
proof but a duck duck 170 don't sleep on
a seven-year sleep on seven year olds
yeah dude so I messaged me so this um
shoutouts - I'm so sorry for your name
but he's like older he's like in his
late 60s early 70s and he's like yeah I
don't sleep on us like some old people -
that looks so [ __ ] good it makes me
so [ __ ] mad because as a young person
I don't even look like that like Elon
Musk mom she looks so good
what does she look like is she high
number that one dude that one like young
young like skied a black dude he had
like the gray [ __ ] he was like all
children
oh he dressed all like GQ sixties [ __ ]
[ __ ] that guy oh yeah
yeah yeah her name is Mei musk she's so
pretty the model holy [ __ ] she looks
like Corona the baby girl
yeah she's that woman is going to take
my soul dude she's beautiful so
beautiful she looks like she's a cover
girl model well in the palm that's crazy
mom right now Oh what was she doing in
the past I don't know he's done proud
she's fine he hasn't always been a model
I don't know it's be product first I
didn't even know that was his mom now
yeah she's fire mmm
what does Jack Maz mom look like Jack my
love you do just because you're rich I
don't know this is mom but it's like the
old food she might just look like your
head I hope not but looks like he was
created a [ __ ] tube it's all right
yeah yeah I don't know he'd the richer
and older he got the [ __ ] his
everything grew but his face yeah oh
dude
this face is expanded but that face we
stayed in the same in Jack Ma making a
film right a kung fu
he's in he's attaching mash you up to
promote his [ __ ] no no do you like your
emails yeah
hit me up jack my what John Gorrie
[ __ ] ugly ass [ __ ]
no I just wonder what his mom what did
you say watch employee goalie less it
sound like your throw up dude watch out
golden Chinese language yeah why'd you
speak some [ __ ] Chinese right now cuz
speak to me uh new hammer no no no not
the basic [ __ ] everybody knows that's
Dustin so we learned so far no impress
us right Oh both of you want and
precious right now most important why
out Chen that is correct
she says I want money anymore [ __ ]
Korean Chinese we need to know the two
Asian stereotypes found each other
perfectly true I tried really best car I
don't give a [ __ ] about the law and I
buy my group beat me actually dreamt
last night about our Mandarin class for
some reason like a dreamt that I was in
it without you because you know you're
not doing anymore and then I was like
really
wait so you had you had your in the
classroom and you're studying yeah and
my dream wasn't that class it was like
an actual class you guys made me want to
pick up a [ __ ] third language man and
take it with them
nah oh yeah take it anymore I don't like
I don't like learning in a class setting
though I had to do it on my own volition
like yeah when I get into a class
sitting I start wanting to disrupt [ __ ]
like high school again only reason why I
even remembered how all the [ __ ] that I
learned in Japanese was after school I
didn't learn it in school I'm gonna on
my own I did the Pimsleur thing I [ __ ]
watch TV shows like I asked that's the
only way I learned
but in class I learned [ __ ] zilch but
only reason I passed that [ __ ] because
it's girl named Jenny hang let me copy
off her every day
what if someone learned Japanese from
just watching Japanese porn and in they
sound like a Japanese porn star what
does that sound like
tell me something missing right there
done done you no no she that's what
she's telling you to tell her something
to say I don't know what's that what's
the Japanese porn word what don't give
me a porn word this givers under the
saying Suge porn eyes it says you're a
Japanese guy give me a word to translate
committal with translate is your dough
is your dick eg yeah I guess
Oh Jim Pocock I Iike are you are you
hungry
we're not gonna sleep that damn does
this keep doing this dude I'm getting
hot did you take a shower or a bath or
whatever that's only has been poor no
I'm just coming up with words that
aren't important but you're gonna
fortify our oh oh oh hi baby time no
need Tidus car or food or no [ __ ] you
yeah you [ __ ] me uh this is my first
time okay I don't know
wait this is my first time do you want
to kiss me I don't know if I wanna hug
it's just a hug or see this guy okay
yeah it's no cause like I'm trying to
translate certain things but then I'm
not that good either so then hug or like
call Jess WASC her Korean but like you
know Japanese porn net born way okay
what do you want me to say well I guess
I guess if a girl said it in a demure
way to say the same gotcha holla that's
how I would say that now would they be
like the slain wave I feel like Japanese
porn they like pause and they like pitch
like yeah they do
much yet maybe even higher than what
you're speaking right now it's like dude
this is gonna be the highest viewed
video ever dude
[Music]
[Music]